hey what's up guys thanks for tuning in
to are you garbage please make sure you
go subscribe to the youtube channel that
way you get the videos
as they come out yeah do it
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage
show we sit down with your favorite
comedians and find out they grew up
classy
or if they're a big old piece of trash
i'm your host stage foley coming at you
on a beautiful day here
down the basement aunt tooty's basement
the holiday season is in bloom she
hasn't gotten the decorations put up
down here
because her hip's been bothering her and
i got to go up in the attic and get the
box i told her i could do it saturday
my co-host is coming at you from right
next to me he's my best pal
in the whole wide world if i could be
with this guy
every second of every day man that would
be my little slice of heaven
give it up for kevin james ryan
everybody hey gang you're laying it on a
little too thick everybody what's up
thanks
for christmas bonus time coming up what
are you talking about he's going to
butter up
you got to butter up the ceo get a
little bit of gage what's up everybody
thanks for tuning in as always please
make sure you rate review subscribe on
itunes
full video is available on youtube and
then obviously the bread and butter
patreon.com
are you garbage uh you can sign up you
can get bonus videos every you can get
bonus episodes every week of ru garbage
you can get bonus episodes of hard
feelings
where it's me and foley [ __ ] letting
it fly see behind the curtain a little
bit
chopping it up also uh at the end of
every month with uh the highest level we
do a live stream where you get to ask us
questions we get to ask you questions
we'll play the game with you it'll be a
good [ __ ] time check it out
patreon.com
are you grubby yes of course and of
course you want to pick up a little ayg
swag go over to podcastmerch.com
and grab yourself a t or a hoodie yep
and a little bit of shout out to our old
pal
our producer extraordinaire the magic
man t-bone
tebow toby mcmullen soon to be
unemployed
a little bit behind the curtain here
t-bone just just botched the recording
we lost the first 20 minutes
a little bit of a back backstory we were
in the [ __ ] middle of a heartfelt
intense tale from our very special guest
that we have here today
and we're gonna do it one more time for
you because we're three four
professionals
three and a half five and a half if you
count fully
dude something just came out of your
nose oh my god slow-mo that
punch in on that and it's slo-mo oh my
god
i think that was the vaccine or
something
his antibodies running away gang we
couldn't be more excited to have our old
pal our very special guest here with us
today
he is a very funny stand-up comedian and
podcaster he is the host of two
jacked bros and a good pal of ours he's
had a [ __ ] up childhood yeah crazy
we're about to come back
[Laughter]
round two of [ __ ] psycho tales give
it up
for sydney gant everybody oh thank you
so much
we're sorry about it they could tell
this all over again not a problem i
think the
the the craziest part about it is i
don't think it was [ __ ] up but
you were a little vague with the details
a little bit some of the things i wanted
to know but then we eventually we got to
it
so tell us the story again you grew up
in a town called pottstown
pottstown pennsylvania which is a little
bit of a rural
town right about an hour 15 minutes
outside of philadelphia
mm-hmm and uh you know we were just we
were just
it's a scrappy little town like like uh
we have
wrestling champions from there yeah i'm
aware and uh
so uh one of the things that we always
do at the end of every
you know play session with all the kids
is we would all fight each other before
we all win which is insane to me like
it's just like this unspoken role that
everybody just starts punching each
other but we'll make sense in a couple
of minutes yes
not only was it an unspoken rule that
everybody punched each other if you try
to leave then you got it
people would come after you damn like
nobody would leave you couldn't leave
if you didn't throw a punch or take a
punch
i would have been like my asthma's
bothering me something i would have
[ __ ] you know what i mean i got flat
feet i see you guys in math
yeah trying to try to duck it like the
draft
i got a doctor's note i can't do it i
mean i was i believe it or not i was
actually
a hard attempted ducker of that
you tried to duck it every single time
really every single time but like the
only
what i would do is like just like throw
myself into it really quickly like take
a couple of lumps and then just try to
bounce
yeah get it over like a band-aid like a
mosh pit yeah
yeah i wasn't i wasn't i wasn't i wasn't
necessarily
i wouldn't say that was tough yeah what
age we talking
it's so that stopped in when i was about
15-16
but that was again because uh guns
started to get introduced like
the climate the town changed very
dramatically at that time
so damn did any of your friends have
guns
uh later on yeah but these are like
like you said rural yes people so they
have like rifles and [ __ ] like that
well see here's the thing we're a rural
town that should be
a suburban town so no nobody thinks
they're rural
in that town gotcha that's a dangerous
country yeah it really is
hillbillies who don't know their
hillbillies yeah it's a double-edged
sword
damn for sure yikes yeah
all right and what's the backstory with
your family hit us with that
because that will connect why you
that'll bring us up this way we're
fighting each other in parking lots
after [ __ ] birthday parties
that that happened yeah of course it did
shout out to chuck e cheese i can throw
a mean left hook that rat had it coming
i tell you
yeah so you know i was like you know i
grew up with
a single mom for the most part although
my my dad lived in the town and
i was i would see my dad pretty often
okay okay
weekly monthly what are we talking i
mean
as as often as i wanted to you know that
far gotcha you know
so to some degree it was it would be on
me sometimes yeah if i was willing to
take the bike trick
trip over there if i was like sometimes
i would be like
really sitting there making the
decisions like i'm going to play
basketball to see my dad today yeah
yeah so i played a lot of basketball
hell of a jumper
kid's got a hell of a shot yeah so uh
you know that wasn't
until sixth grade uh i lived with my mom
and then we moved
my brother and i moved my grandma my
sister ran away from home
and then my mom moved to coatesville it
was just we just kind of got scattered
into the wind
right and uh you know so that that was
basically
my home life this was up until sixth
grade up until sixth grade
now your mother was a big part of your
life back then
yeah man influence my mom was a big part
of the town back then
and tell the folks out there what she
did her hobbies
what did her hot crossword puzzles
sudoku yeah no so my mom
uh which is again it's a very hard thing
to explain to people
uh my mom she was a she was a street
fighter
and so when i say that like everybody oh
yeah my mom would like get loud like
yeah my mom would get loud and fight
people at grocery stores too but that
like she would fight in scheduled fights
dude that's in [ __ ] insane
my mom worked at a dentist
dude the only fight i ever saw my mom
almost getting is i think i might have
talked about it on this
the this family from uh flower town
moved into like our neighborhood they
hit the lottery or it was like
there was like a [ __ ] slip and fall
accident or something came across a
couple million bucks
so they were real trashy and moved in i
got beat i got hit in the face with a
hockey stick we were playing hockey i
didn't face the hockey stick by the one
that was my age
my brother came out to be like yo what
the [ __ ] and then his older brother beat
up my older brother
and then my mom comes out we're both
like bloody on the front yard
and she goes and starts screaming at the
mom and i'm like well you're going to
get [ __ ] worked lady like
his family's going to [ __ ] run
through us it's like the guy that
knocked out deebo for the bird
the guy depot knocked out for the bike
coming down here messing with these
people
yeah that's crazy my my uh so my i come
from a family of fighters like
i'm probably the least fighty of my
family yeah
and for the list we've went over this
and the part that we lost but sydney is
pure [ __ ] bonkers crazy person
not looking for confrontation but
definitely
not running away from it no i think i
need it
yeah to some degree to feel stable okay
so this town
had this almost circuit of underground
fighting
yeah so my so i mean if you don't if you
know anything about pottstown
uh pa it's uh it's a town that kind of
builds professional athletes too
and we have professional football
players basketball players uh
an olympic bronze medalist in wrestling
like we produce
pretty pretty good athletes and your
mother was recognized
in this circuit for being one of the
toughest people oh my mom's a legend in
my town
damn undefeated street fighter do you
have any idea what a ballpark purse
would be
for something like this because i would
imagine
with the with gambling on the fights
there would have to be
a pretty decent amount of money at stake
not like millions of dollars but
obviously yeah probably a couple of
hundred couple one thousand
[ __ ] stuff in the 80s the 90s yeah i
mean so i'll say this
i never knew exactly how much money she
won but uh
one year for school she bought all of me
and my brother's school clothes
with money she won from one fight damn
that's pretty good
ballin and bradley i love it she was
like so proud that she was she was
buying
all of her school clothes with fight
money that she didn't even
she wasn't even like trying to uh
micromanage what i bought it was all
windbreakers yeah
see she let me get all windbreakers she
also made me buy a couple of long giants
to wear under him for the winter but
yeah
she turns into oscar de la hoya i love
it
whatever you want at the end of the day
she's still a great mom gotta get long
johns
you gotta stay warm that's great
was she was she strict with you about
what you did
she was only strict that we had to work
hard and get good grades
because you are you are a very
calculated thorough you know critical
thing you're you're not like
wild or you know like you're very you're
very intelligent very smart very
calculated person
and you see that's you know you would
say on the surface the
the underground fighting is garbage but
then when you say that
no it's garbage i mean you'll say that
on the surface at the bottom on the top
underground i mean yeah it's pretty
gorgeous so discipline with their kids i
don't know i would give a little
give a little leeway on that well yeah
she did a great job with him but she's
still a [ __ ] backyard brawler
i mean like she's in a fight car
[Laughter]
man yeah me my brother-in-law i think
i've met her maybe i think i might have
met her at one point i think i did yeah
my brother and i we talk about this a
lot it's like because my brother's a
good guy too he
he's like uh you know a boss at his job
like he's a
he's a hard-working dude okay and uh
it's like she accidentally raised good
kids too
yeah yeah it was but not accidentally
she put the screws to you
not really i mean my mom was she i don't
i don't even think
i can't remember even getting like yell
she wouldn't try to intimidate us
really no not at all because she was
very uh
she was very into the idea of us being
polite you know
just like being well known you are very
well mannered
very polite very respectful always sorry
thank you very
much were you scared of her growing up
was there like an unwritten
was this i'm scared of her now did she
not have to be that way
because you were already petrified of
her
no she my mom is uh so
one time when she thought my sister was
afraid of her
she made my sister fight her like we
weren't allowed to talk about school the
hard times yeah get outside here and
fight your mom
pack of wolves over there cause my mom
was my mom's whole thing is like she
there's like no cowards in her house so
like
i was one of those kids so i would never
want to tell my mom
i get it that i was made so it's like
you're not going to be afraid of
anything yes
face it all you're never going to be
afraid so here's an example hardcore
[ __ ]
it is it's pretty hardcore so here's an
example i think there's a different way
of going around at the right hooks
you can you can instill that instill
that theory in people without [ __ ]
punching them in the head i'm sitting
there like i don't know i'm on the fence
so my so my name is sydney but everybody
calls me scotty
right in my my town and so i was
i was sydney until my first day at
kindergarten right
i come home so in kindergarten they do
the roll call
sydney i raised my hand a couple kids
laughed about it because they thought it
was going to be a girl
oh yeah and i just thought that was like
the funniest thing
you know it was hilarious like these
like i'm not a girl they think i'm a
girl
i went home and i just told my mom like
oh they thought i was a girl yeah my
name was a great misdirect
and she was like so right then and there
she was like
no they're never calling you sydney at
that school again she went to school the
next day
and told them to start calling me scotty
and then the the kids that made fun of
me
she took me to their houses to fight
them oh
my god first day of kindergarten did you
win
uh what did the other mom say yeah no
the other mom wasn't having it yeah
how about that saturday morning the
doorbell rings
oh it's the gantz what can we do for you
bring timmy's little [ __ ] out here
[Laughter]
wow yeah oh i love it holy [ __ ] so
that's what we're talking about here
yeah i was one of those kids i was one
of those kids getting trotted around to
fight people so
i could never even i could never even
let my mom
know that like i remember when this one
uh big kid
sharon greenwich kind of moved to the
area we were living in he's just he was
like way bigger than he should have been
for this we had a couple those kids were
always they
transferred in and they were like the
tough guy for a little while but
eventually somebody got them yeah it's
like where'd you come from the power
plant what the [ __ ]
happened and i i avoided him with
everything that i could
because he was a little bit of a bully
sure and it was like if if
i get in any interaction with him my mom
is going to make me fight this guy
so i stayed away from him as much as i
could and then uh one day he shot me in
the chest with a pellet gun
jesus christ and my mom like i came home
crying about it
uh like through my shirt it was like
lodged into my chest
i'm freaking out about it she's looking
at it she's like what happened i'm like
charon shot me with a pellet gun
she said he did what she took me back to
his house
with a pellet lodged in my chest oh my
god
to fight this dude and it's like i
wouldn't want to fight him now
yeah you know what i mean it's like are
you kidding me yeah he's
dude sharon is like six eight now geez
how did that go
uh i got my ass kicked no luckily his
dad wouldn't let it happen sure you know
his his and he also his dad beat the
[ __ ] out of him in front of us
really yeah damn your town's too
touching
[ __ ] wild holy [ __ ] you guys ever
hear of a timeout or anything what the
[ __ ]
go to the mall grab a soft pretzel or
something will you
taking a movie jesus christ i'm pretty
sure timeouts were invented when i was
like 10.
[ __ ] i've been missing out on these [ __ ]
you get a timeout when you're knocked
out that's the time
the only time that you got was when you
got sent to the corner yeah you put an
ice cream
you got to cut me myself in a bucket
timeout between rounds yeah your cut man
shows
up she's like i told you work the chat
like i'm [ __ ] trying the kid's six
six he's in third grade we're in a
mouthpiece to school every day
yeah oh man i totally would never [ __ ]
with you ever now
knowing all of this not that i ever
would but yeah i'm a nice guy
you know for sure it was like but and
that's the thing too like my mom
she she just you know so she would fight
all these ladies
and you know we weren't allowed to go to
these fights but like we snuck out to a
few of them
and that has to do i'm sorry to cut you
off that has to
believing in i don't know what the word
an impression [ __ ] you up
going sneaking out and watching through
people's legs your mom
fight another person yeah have you met
him what the [ __ ] this is what we're
talking about
fully that's why i'm here yeah for sure
[ __ ] them up that's why he's in the
basement baby
now do you think that affected you at
all sydney
[Laughter]
but i mean on such a level because you
couldn't be able to understand because
i'm just thinking about
things that i saw when i was a kid that
i didn't understand yeah
and seeing that your parents [ __ ] has
he uptight
upside down like that well um i will say
this though uh
as far as like something that is
impacting a child consistently
throughout their lives
like fighting is very honest
you see people in their truth so
you know if if my my mom won every fight
she was in but
it was uh it was there's just something
really pure
about two people in a fight so
i mean it was i was pretty sick i'm not
gonna lie to you yeah it's [ __ ] dope
yeah like the only the part that sucked
about it is that sometimes
she would fight people's moms who i
wanted to be friends with
and that's a tough sleepover
my mom said hi by the way sorry about
breaking your orbital
rematch next march what are you thinking
yeah sleepovers
sucked damn i i i had to leave
multiple sleepovers because there would
be
not necessarily the person who's like
the parents whose house it was
but other people had to sleep over like
my mom had fought their mom
and they would have an issue with it and
then it was just a whole thing i would
just like
leave jesus [ __ ] crying did she ever
get in trouble with the police or
anything like that
no the po so again paz town is a
fighting town
so if the police showed up to a fight
situation they'd let
they let them duke it out and then just
so no i've never seen my mom get in
trouble with the police god
damn that is hardcore was it
was it bare knuckle boxing or were they
uh yeah they they showed up as-is
oh toby you sweet little country bumpkin
out of curiosity was michael buffer
there
[Laughter]
people selling peanuts toby's asking
that was a school newspaper question
right
now excuse me
look in the back oh what size glove
sweeping
are you doing 16 ouncers what are you
thinking headgear no headgear
they carpool to the fight dude holy [ __ ]
now how has that affected sydney now
because
you do a little you do some mixed
martial arts stuff and
all that right yeah i've been doing
martial arts since i was a kid so
when like growing up in that type of
house my mom wanted everybody to be able
to fight
and family business yeah
it really is so my mom would go to uh
she would she would train at a boxing
gym
so that was always a really interesting
thing to watch because the
most of the ladies that she fought were
just people that thought they were tough
yeah but my mom was actually a skilled
trainer was she
was she a bigger or smaller i mean
picture like small and whiter she's like
uh like
maybe five two damn fit you know like
just
right now i wouldn't she's she's looking
a little round lately to me do you think
your mom could cover it because your mom
beat me up right now
i probably not you're a big guy
yeah but he's too big he's broken it's
the law of diminishing returns
so i will say this uh if you don't knock
her out in 30 seconds you're in trouble
yeah
30 dude 30 seconds
i have the cardio for like six seconds
yeah yeah then yes
he doesn't get a hold of him patreon
patreon
yo go get mrs gant that'll be on the 50
i would let her tune me up
yeah you can put a little put a little
boxing ring in here
watch that
dude i would pay i would join the
patreon to watch her beat you up
i tell you what watching the fact i get
beat up is pretty good yeah that's good
tv i'll tell you that right now
i don't mind it all right so you so she
trained as a boxer
you're into mixed martial arts tonight
your wife is into something jiu-jitsu
you guys all do yeah so so what happened
so when when i was a kid
jesus christ the whole [ __ ] squad
well this it's all
it's the only thing that makes sense to
me the kids do your kids do it my kids
absolutely i feel like everybody should
like train in fighting
to some degree because it just mellows
you out
a little bit you know like uh you know
like like kevin was saying like i don't
i don't
necessarily try to start fights with
people but i will
let you escalate the situation to a
fight you know but i'm not gonna try to
escalate it okay i remember one time
outside of a place that's real psychosis
yeah on south street i was like out
there smoking and some i think it was me
and you out there we were on south
street
and there was this weird interaction
with this guy who like asked for a cig
or something like me and you hanging out
front
and like i saw it i'm like i gotta end
this now otherwise it's gonna be a thing
right i'm like yeah whatever man like
you know have a good one and like
sydney's like so where are you from i
like kept the conversation going and i'm
like
all right like like a spider yeah like
you're not walking you're not walking
away from it
you're definitely not like gonna just
hit the guy but you're also like hey i'm
down for wherever this goes
i am game and i'm also i'm also
conscious of other people around me too
so
i thought you were gonna bring up that
time in the back of raven there were
these two black eyes that were showing
up they weren't comedians but they
showed up for a couple weeks straight i
vaguely remember this
by people yeah and one day you and i
were in the back
of the room and they oh right holy [ __ ]
i forgot about this
so they were trying to intimidate kevin
and me in the back of the room
and i forgot about this so get me out of
flex on some [ __ ]
it started to escalate it was getting
like chestnuts yeah
and i remember i'll never forget this
this is this is probably the day that i
was like i [ __ ] love kevin
right because i looked over at him don't
hit me man
i'm on the phone with my dad i'm calling
sydney's mom real quick
hey how do i throw a hook
so i look over at kevin he's he's
jerking both of them all
[Laughter]
and i'm like [ __ ] it kevin he's a good
kid
no i i look over at kevin and again like
he has this look on his face like
it basically says i don't want to do
this but i will if it has to happen yeah
and i saw that and i was like all right
we're good
we're good and i just let it go so i'm
not i'm not gonna
try to get anybody else involved in
anything
that's that's a big thing for me like to
the point that
like if somebody doesn't like me
i'm like listen don't defend me to him
like if we if we have a person
like in our mutual circle that doesn't
like me just let him dislike
don't you don't stick up for me you like
to work alone huh
yeah yeah he's definitely got a go bag
under the bed in case he's got a [ __ ]
in case he's gotta split down a couple
of passports a stack of ten grains holy
[ __ ] a couple of pain pills
yeah wow i forgot about that story holy
[ __ ] yeah that was great that was
crazy that was crazy it was just
because i remember i said something to
him i was like yo like i was like yo
i was like you guys got to go and he's
like what are you going to do about it
and it was like
one of those things and i just didn't i
don't know what i said exactly but it
was like what like
whatever i have like whatever we want to
do we can do or something like that
and then his buddy stood up or something
then you stood up and we were like
yeah and they were like yeah we're like
yeah they go i will leave and we're like
dude gentlemen the second they walked
out that door i looked over and said i'm
like
i thought i was gonna get my ass kicked
thank god my black friend hopped up
[ __ ] flex am i in the gang now
[ __ ] nerd
want to go to pottstown if kevin lost
the fight you would have driven him to
those guys
[Laughter]
i'm crying sydney i don't want to do it
talking to his parents at the front door
like who are you
[Laughter]
my mom would have stopped making me be
friends with kevin you can't be hanging
out with that fat ryan
no more sleepovers at the pussy's house
oh
man the good old days whoo i love it
let's see let's get into a couple of
yeah i'm interested what we're here for
i'm i'm gonna go okay now
with what you just told us being what it
is
do you think you're garbage man i i feel
like i'm going to make the same mistake
ryan schainer said but i
i do not think i'm guarded i don't think
you are either
i i think this is
i think you're i don't know sydney's
very
oddly opinionated on things he's kind of
like all like already
like your opinion on things that most
people don't have opinions on
and you stick to your gut and it's just
very weird you like it's like an onion
you're like
what the [ __ ] are you doing so i don't
know i bet you he's very disciplined i
bet you everything's
probably organized i don't think the
kids probably get to eat bad foods are
they probably on a good diet
no i don't think so well am i wrong here
are you going to hit me i mean i choke
them out now
you're you're not wrong but you're not
completely right either so i so i
grew up eating pretty healthy right you
know and
you know when your mom's fighting with a
[ __ ] holy shield i guess you would
yeah
she's got to make weight
[Laughter]
all that road work a lot of boiled
chicken you know
drinking the eggs like rocky he's got
him in his bottle
yeah so there was a i also like uh
the the everybody in my dad's side of
the family becomes like diabetic and
loses the foot
so my mom was just like you just that's
not happening yeah
okay so i was i was you know i was like
like mcdonald's was a big treat
you know yeah for us and then and it
took a long time for me to even get used
to the taste of mcdonald's like i didn't
get used to the taste of mcdonald's
until i was a teenager working there
you worked you may work tonight
dude he's like one of those people on
the internet that beats the [ __ ] out of
the
beats the [ __ ] out of the customers for
running their mouth
crawling through the drive-through with
frosty all over them
[ __ ] choking some guy out in his car
yeah i was i was working on the grill
man i was like
i was trying to be a ladies man at that
time so i was like i was more likely to
finger a chicken
in the freezer oh yeah i like it cold
huh
the ice man coming could have hit the
broom closet um
all right well we're familiar with where
you came up pottstown area right
what the big one is what grocery store
did you go to growing up and what do you
go to now that you're
a family man you have your own family
what do you what do you do now
so uh it was super fresh that turned
into a giant and now i'm still a giant
guy
that ain't too bad not at all that's
pretty good yeah
giant's all right i was a super fresh
kid growing up too yeah but then they
changed at some point they got bought
out or something
so that's a lot of them flopped i didn't
realize that superfresh was a little
bit of a lower budget groceries compared
to
giant i think i think giant might have
bought them out and
it was a little more upscale okay i
didn't realize that but it was for me
the brand recognition was like i'm a
super fresh guy it's giant now so i'm a
giant guy yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's not shabby at all
that's pretty good mm-hmm
well what were you gennard's weiss yeah
ginardi's and then
giant yeah of course yeah yeah but there
wasn't the bloodbaths going on in the
[ __ ] streets and bluebells
if you would have said we got our own
meat from the woods i'd have been like
all right that makes sense
well we only eat what we he'll hunt so
you hit me with a giant see
see i'm telling you this is gonna be
it's gonna it's called gonna pan out
it's all gonna work out uh
i got one too what'd you get on your
sats uh the first time i got a 1490. you
see
oh yeah because they're straight
fighting every weekend
yeah but it's also guys it's like so the
town that i live the part of the town
that i lived in we grew up in a
like a government subsidized housing
development a 1490
yeah but so here so hear me out though
so in that
that's the highest one we've gotten i
think a 1400 yeah was the biggest was
the best we had before
you should have been in like the cia or
something like that oh you would be a
great fb but you're supposed to follow
us
he doesn't like rules you know yeah he
doesn't like rules
special forces you should have done
delta force
but again you would have to follow rules
to that point
you know he could never make it there no
it's you know it
again oh you would have got discharged
for doing something [ __ ] up
i don't know i don't know i'm i don't
like to get caught doing things
that was so weirdly said that was so
cool there's cameras on you right now
buddy boys
so don't get any [ __ ] ideas
yeah like i've never i've never gotten
in trouble for anything
ever i have never been in because it's
like if if i was doing something
and i'm like we're with people and
somebody's being a little rowdy about it
i'm gone like i like to hang out with
people that know how to keep it
clandestine
clandestine i like to say clandestine
yeah 14.90 my ass
maybe a 940. hey we'll say whatever way
you want to say a big guy
yeah i've heard it three ways
[Laughter]
so you were a good student yes i was a
good student was uh would you guys sit
down and like have dinner every night
together as a family growing up
no it was uh she would cook dinner and
we just had to eat
what do you mean it's just like she
would cook dinner and we would like
serve herself you could eat when you eat
yeah so it was like a lot of uh a lot of
times
we we would hang out around each other a
lot but we weren't always doing the same
thing at the same time so
like one of us would be eating others or
watching tv
like eat with the people watching tv i
got you yeah
all right but you're but so your mother
was a good mom other than the street
fighting
i don't think they're necessarily
connected right like you can be a good
mom
outside of street fighting right yeah i
mean she had
she had moments of being a good mom i
mean because
because again like i don't want my
brother watching this man what the [ __ ]
you saying she's a good mom for it
i love how that's what your brother
would get upset about
[ __ ] i want people walking around
thinking she was good
[ __ ] that's [ __ ] i gotta rep the
president i thought you're gonna say i
don't want you telling people she was
abandoned
yeah that's what i yeah no here's the
thing she's like she's super supportive
of everything that i do right
she really believes in my potential to
do anything
right but at the same time like we
didn't have a very stable house
like we i think the longest i ever lived
in one place was eight months
damn damn yeah so she unfortunately when
you when you are a fighter and you hold
yourself in a high regard like that
the way normal people get down is
infuriating
so she would be at work and she worked
in a lot of nursing homes and stuff
she didn't like the cattiness right
because she didn't talk about people
behind her back unless she went to [ __ ]
them up
so when she would hear that people were
talking about her she would always go to
that person
and say look please keep my name out of
your mouth or i'm going to choke you in
the break room
right so here's a crazy story
oh here's a crazy story dude
not any time my mom enrolled me in a
[ __ ] toddler fight club
here's a crazy story
so again so uh when i was uh by the time
i was in sixth grade
we i lived in i think it was 11
different places in the same town
that's like military style yeah yeah it
was pretty crazy because she would get
in a fight at work get evicted
and then she would just have to piece
something together to get somewhere else
but she wouldn't right away because she
knows that since she works in nursing
homes all the time she'll always be able
to find another job
okay so she would just like linger chill
a bit until like everything started to
fall apart
and then once everything fell apart then
she'd get her [ __ ] together gotcha
so we were constantly you know being
chased out of houses
all the time damn right and uh
i forget what story i was gonna tell oh
in the break room sounded tricky
so so flash forward to
uh you know i'm about like maybe 35 like
five years ago okay
my son was definitely born when this was
happening for the first time in my mom's
life
she worked at a job for more than
a year okay holy [ __ ] and we we all went
out to dinner and
where did you go out to dinner uh was it
uh it was like a chain restaurant in
king of prussia applebee's
cheesecake a little yeah it was like a
cheesecake factory okay little yeah did
you guys all beat the waitress up in the
parking lot
little family activity she ran her mouth
on the way
that was the tip we gave her keep your
hands up
[ __ ] jump the hostess
[Laughter]
hi how can i help you this evening just
gets pummeled
so so this is it's a big deal to her
and she i don't know how she's engaging
with people at work but
uh my mom's like a super confident
person and she
talks a lot of [ __ ] right so these women
at her work decided they didn't like her
and they were trying to get her fired
just this place she'd been after the
year for the year yeah so
they lied on her and said that she
attacked somebody in the break room they
choked she choked somebody in the break
room right
very specific language that they chose
for that because
one of them got a hold of her files her
previous file where she said i'll choke
you in the
break room right so now this is like my
brother and my sister did not believe my
mom that she did not do this to this
lady i don't believe her that she didn't
do it to this lady
i don't
she had never lied to me about a fight
before as a matter of fact she
loves to brag about every fight that
she's in and
i was telling this is why i say it's not
garbage right here
it's an honor he's going to tell us that
she for sure choked the woman out of it
maybe afterwards
yeah no this for sure happened so
it gets it gets this turns into a big
turn
now we have lawyers involved right
because
my my mom's like i didn't do this
they're lying and like
the people that are in human resources
they're involved in this
so now we got lawyers involved so
because that happened
we got a lot of files on my mom like her
whole entire work history from like the
80s
until this moment right dude it was like
not looking good it was like a pack
you could it was thick it's like it's
like wolverines
so me and andy are yeah are looking
through it
and it's just like page after page of
attacked women in a break room choked
woman
insane but it ended up being true ended
up being true like she
didn't she didn't do that they lost the
lawsuit
yeah closed down the nursing home oh my
god should she get a little bit of cash
she want a big loss
she didn't win she didn't win money from
the lawsuit but she she won her honor i
guess
okay she was compensated
a little bit but it wasn't it wasn't
like a big loss
is she working out or is she is she
riding off that no she's working
that that money good for her did not
last long i got you a lot of
windbreakers
i don't know i don't know that was on
the episode we lost but
i forget where it was all right huh okay
interesting what about now what kind of
person are you now like um
like when i say you're not garbage i you
know and i see discipline
brush your teeth in the shower oh if i'm
late
okay yeah you know it's uh
but dude so you don't keep the
toothbrush in the shower no i would not
do that yeah
okay yeah i i'm so sorry every time
something that i pass over then i'm like
i'm not that garbage i keep looking at
folks because he is that guard
this is this is his wheelhouse yeah um i
got one for you
you're in public right you're whatever
and you have to uh
go you have to go to the bathroom number
two how do you clean the public toilet
seat
uh i'm garbage [ __ ] nothing you just
killed everybody
wow and listen dude
he's seen [ __ ] man yeah it's like it
doesn't give a [ __ ] about pooping in the
kingdom pressure mall bathroom
if it looks okay to me yeah i'll plop
down
damn yeah that's wild yeah but i also
in in my defense i i we like
did a lot of chores growing up so i know
with a compromised toilet seat
sure sure i also only handicap stall
smart but i hear there's a rule that
everybody does that so that's actually
the more used one
uh it doesn't seem like it okay all
right okay
okay okay um do you sneak snacks into
the movie theater
um antsy does my wife does okay what
were you talking about like
candies and stuff like that are you
sneaking in like fast food
fast food sandwiches stuff that doesn't
make sound sandwiches that's the are you
stopping it like wawa to get sandwiches
are you making them at home
oh that's trash i'm pulling back now
i was like i thought that was gonna be
the trash i think no
i disagree i think odor odor is the big
thing if you're making the ham and
cheese at home and having it at the
movies that's fine
if you roll it with chinese food and it
smells like the whole no have the ham
and cheese at home if you're making us
you're at home going what are you
if you're not going to the beach you're
going to a [ __ ] movie i tell you what
tough guy you tell him next time he's
sitting behind you in a movie
the kids get up and stomp you pop let me
handle this
all the gans beats the [ __ ] out of me
yeah that's
it's trash i'm sorry that's trash okay
you're good you're trash you're good
you're good you're good what about your
towel where do your towels go
in the uh in the in the bathroom they go
over the do you hang them
over the uh shower curtain do you have a
designated hook behind the door this
isn't good
or do they go on the door all right i
so it goes it goes on the shower the the
towel rod
i definitely put them on the tower
however
and just in case my wife watches this i
i don't change my towel that's a long
time like my wife has to do it yeah
if she comes in and she gets to the
point where she's like i'm
that's bad yeah i like a fresh one i'm
kind of the same way though wife would
be like
we're i'm watching you're watching this
yeah and i've
i've i've i've almost gotten annoyed
with her
like when she's like i got to take this
towel and i'm like
oh yeah you're right you're right no i
don't
my towel i get a new towel jesus it's
like when she's when she when she
decides that it's just
starting to affect the way she looks as
a person that's what she changes yeah
i get it i get it that's trashy i do the
same thing what about the gantt
vacations now where do you guys go
well it's five of us i have three kids
right
so i mean we we go where we kind of we
can afford
at the time so we we do the beach you
know
when we can and we also sometimes we'll
do uh
what we'll do a trip like we'll get you
know get in a plane and go somewhere oh
yeah usually combined with
uh my wife's brother family you're doing
like a big
like run out of house together okay and
and do that so the
last one of those we did was in san
antonio all right nice
too not too shabby uh have you ever
taken a couch or any other furniture
from the trash
i have not now oh do you get cash back
when you go to like 7 11 or anything
what do you mean like from like atm wise
like or like from the register from the
register
if you're buying a gatorade and they go
do you want cash back
i mean well if yes
[Laughter]
i was about to defend it before i
admitted it let me just admit it first
let me just admit it first but listen
it's better than paying an atm fee
let me just like get this get the snack
i want no
that's why it's garbage that's why it's
garbage do you use the atm to just check
your balance sometimes
no my i i have no idea how much money i
have ever
my wife handles all my stuff really yeah
i don't i mean i don't like to know
because i have
i'm a compulsive spender okay so if i if
i look at my balance and i see
five dollars at five dollars it's gone
immediately
so it's like if i don't know and i just
keep convincing myself i don't have a
lot of money that's smart
yeah it makes it easier to know that
actually is smart yeah
okay i got one i think that i don't know
do you currently or have you ever
carried a pocket knife
yes oh do you have wait now you have one
on you yes
really swiss army though so it's a
multi-tool it's a little
functional yeah is it like the classic
swiss army
no it's just uh well yeah i think i
think we call this the classic one
it's uh probably the most common yeah
yeah yeah that's right
that's all right i'll give you that yeah
is it more functionality or is it more
like if [ __ ] goes down in the streets i
can i can
corkscrew yourself for the toothpick
i'll tell you that i don't know
he's not cutting any threads yeah that's
not for threatening that's for slit
my my mom was always a big thing about
guys knowing how to use tools and having
tools on them
i like that yeah i like can't see i'm
telling you
yeah i'm on the i'm on the fence i'm on
the fence to be honest with you anyone
in your family have calf tattoos
oh god all right this is like this is a
very sneaky way to find out that i'm
garb so
here so no calf tattoos but my sister
has
multiple neck tattoos and one of them is
a tattoo
of her boyfriend's lips or her husband's
lips i forgot to ask you when did she
come back from running away
she never came back she what do you mean
like she never
once went back out once my sister ran
away in sixth grade i never lived with
her again
where did she run away to uh westchester
i believe
to whose house uh another friend who ran
away they lied about how old they were
and they got an apartment
that's pretty funny in sixth grade
she was 44.
how old was he's not really running away
it's moving out at that point how old
was she
uh so i'm she's four years five years
older than me
so like 15. so she would have yeah 15
16.
[ __ ] and they got an apartment together
and that was it she never came back
no well i mean like my mom and my sister
live together now but i never lived with
her again
wow yeah man you'd never hear her run
away actually being successful
she's not successful
you did hear the neck tattoos they got
the first apartment
she's a classic runaway
um you drive do you currently have a
bottle of febreze in your car
because if you do that is trash i do i
know right next to me
yeah it's trash first of all or like
those wipes that's also trashy
i i don't uh just yesterday
uh my wife cleaned out both cars okay so
she
and again like i would i would contend
that she's way more garbage than i am
but
uh she doesn't like when i get those
wipes to have in the car she always gets
rid of them yeah you know and i'm like i
would like to
just keep them under the seat they're
not bothering crazy that's not garbage
either i got febreze
i have rain x glass wipes and i have and
i have under armour
and a lot of boogers or armor so why is
febreze garbage though
well it's just like it's the cheap way
to make your car seem nice
right like it's you get in it's overly
powerful instead of just
continuously cleaning your car on a
regularly scheduled basis or just
leaving it dirty like
i do you're like trying to you're trying
to you put [ __ ] lipstick on a pig you
know what i mean it's like
you get in a car you're like you just i
got it from you get in your car
it's just for breeze you know i've never
this might even be worse
any time i ever had febreze in the car
it was never for the car
what was it for i smoke weed so i would
like just spray and just like kind of
walk through it
all right i get that
you square for smoking doobies yeah
that's why i got it michael here's this
first
yours is for farts mine's the cover-up
sent to mcdonald's
that's what it is so nobody asks
questions uh i have a question
was there a bowl of was there a bowl of
uncracked nuts on the tape on your
that was obviously done before i got the
backstory yeah
uh when was the last time you had an
orangina
i i don't drink sugary drinks
because body is a temple get that pretty
classy yeah but
again it was like i was i wasn't allowed
to growing up like
you were meanwhile trained like crushing
crushing cokes and frescas and [ __ ] like
all the time
you were trained in this she was a
world-class fighter boarding fire yeah
yeah hmm own anything by nerf
currently yes he's got kids got kids
yeah damn well i mean before we had kids
ansley anthony and i had one of those
whistler nerfs oh my god
oh and the kid had that thing that
showed up remember you saw that when you
were a kid yeah who is this there's a
six-year-old could rifle that thing like
400 yards
is there currently a bottle of pam
cooking spray at your house
yes unused okay where to keep the butter
at your house on the counter in the
refrigerator
the refrigerator i would like to keep it
on the counter growing up were you a
counter family
always a counter family butter was
always soft i love soft
butter look at this yeah that's the way
it is an enigma
yeah i like it well my ansley uh she
she likes it cold because she likes to
slice it and eat slices of butter
okay holy [ __ ] i got a i got a i got a
real thing with butter too
dude i i have to leave the kitchen i
can't i can't watch her do it
yeah it's it's making my blood my blood
cold because it's
it's like i put butter on this this is
what she'll do she'll slice
slice and butter keep it on the the
butter knife
bite a muffin chew it and then chase it
with butter
wow wow i know what foley's doing
tonight
[Laughter]
have you ever tried that buddy come on
okay when it comes to butter i've done
it all i've seen it all he's boofed it
i will i will admit that's pretty sick
like
i tried it once just to see what she was
doing it's
pretty wild yeah it's pretty sick
holy [ __ ] okay okay okay
interesting have you ever bought a
product that was as seen on tv
yes ah what was it sid
the the last one was the uh those
glasses
that uh he wanted us to be like oh yeah
the glass yeah
the better for the road the hd
sunglasses oh the one that like that
makes you look like uh like
they're like they're like army like
issues yeah yeah they're like you can
use them
yeah they're pretty sick yeah tactical
yeah the guy looks real tactical on that
it's always in the desert and you can
see the rattlesnake
yeah whatever does it work i think so
i think they work he's just making sure
no one's creeping up on him
he's just waiting out front of the porch
in the middle of the night did you ever
have the sunglasses at the little the
little mirror in the corner you can see
behind you i had those had the whole spy
kit yeah
yeah two weeks ago and [ __ ]
man you're like you guys are like
reminding me all the stuff i should be
getting from my son right now yeah dude
you should be tricking your son the [ __ ]
out yeah couple walkie talkies hook it
up
we have walkie talkies have you ever
taken a photo of the photo of you
on a roller coaster instead of paying
for it
no but here's here's why so anytime we
went to dorney park which was the
amusement park that we went to my dad's
company had like a pavilion
there and if we were from the company we
got our pictures for free
that's a good set of pennies dude yeah
damn that's a
good job right there baby now we're
ready to sign up
not only that we could go any time we
just go to dirty park and like let them
know what pavilion we were with
any time over the summer and we just got
him for free that's [ __ ] dope
that's not too bad i went to durney park
so much in my life so much because like
if if another kid's family was going
you're like oh i'll go
yeah but mom can i go to dirty park with
him you know it's just like i didn't
need any money yeah yeah just go
yeah just hop in and go holy [ __ ] that's
funny
hmm okay i got a i got one or two here
from
uh patreon yeah let's hit it guys if uh
when you join the patreon we'll read
your questions um so this is from
mark this is washing your feet in the
shower who actually does this
if you don't are you garbage talking
about scrubbing them with soap what do
you do
i i wash them well how like who uh what
what's the you know i just you know i
work on my balance and like lift one
foot up
scrub it and then uh for some reason i
never lift the second foot up i always
bend down to do the second foot yeah
because you don't want to
you might have soap on the bottom of
your foot it's a it's a safety program
let's go with that
yeah i cannot do
either of those things so what i have is
a little suction cup thing that looks
like a foot that has bristles on it
a little foot scrubber it looks like a
flip-flop that you stick to the bottom
of the of the tub and you stick your and
you
bend over and put some soap on it and
then i feel like he's going to say
that's garbage but before he does that's
[ __ ] genius yeah no that's great you
know what i mean it's gorgeous that's he
has to do it that way that's different
it's not a luxury it's a must uh i'm the
i've
i
have the most guard i don't think i've
ever cleaned the bottom of my feet
the water does it i'm in the i'm in the
shower baby gravity does that
i'm standing in the water for ten
minutes you gotta soak them up a little
bit it's the soap that cleans
well it all goes onto the ground baby
i'm step i'm waddling in the shampoo the
conditioner a little bit of [ __ ] whatever
you got
do you move your feet back and forth to
try to like i don't even
i don't even think i think about it to
be honest i don't it's never registered
my mind
yeah i would love to see the bottom of
your feet patreon.com
i don't think it's exciting let me get a
selfie with the bottom
you're a pavilion member you get it for
free
that's a quick fizz on kippy's park i
got one
okay go have you ever made a dish at
home that used tater tots as the main
ingredient
well i also smoke weed okay so of course
okay yeah dude i remember that's garbage
i dude i made a i made a [ __ ] whole
tray of frozen tater tots
that's all it was i think i sprinkled a
little cheese and some sriracha on it
all [ __ ] banged up one night my wife
woke up i was like what are you doing i
was like i'm in heaven right now
[Laughter]
you slap an egg on there yeah fantastic
um
okay i i have once put tater tots on top
of spaghetti
wow trashy but i don't hate it dude it
was i never did it i never did it again
how do you get it i feel like that's
tough to get all together
uh it wasn't okay and it's also
it's also too uh because normally i
actually did do it twice
because normally i like to cook my tater
tots they're they're
cooked all the way but still a little
soft on the outside
yeah i'm not not super crunchy but it
doesn't work well with this
guy i had the the next time i did it
which was probably like
my second plate i like heated the tater
tops up more so they were crunchy
yeah man in the spaghetti like a crouton
i might do that again yeah
sounds good to me all right i got one or
two more here from patreon
and then we go to wrap it up um this is
from ayur i hope i'm pronouncing the
correct
a-i-u-r um have you ever shared a
toothbrush or used someone else's razor
i don't think so yeah using somebody
else's razor is a
tough look i've done it i've done it
with my brother i've done it with my i
did it i did it last night with my lady
your brother oh really what are you
shaving with us with a where where'd you
shave it down here on the neck
she got some like instagram one duded
[ __ ] it's it's like it's like
[ __ ] butter daddy oh yeah i feel it
feels fantastic she uses my razor
[ __ ] so like technically i do share a
razor with somebody but it's not your
choice
i would yeah it's not and she she also
will use my toothbrush like it's
like nothing oh really yeah oh that's
savage
yeah did you ever have to use it when it
was wet already does she not have a
toothbrush what's going on
no she does but if like so we use an
electronic toothbrush that has the
replacement heads
so we have the one electronic toothbrush
but then the multiple heads
and if she puts my head like if my head
is on the toothbrush already
and she uses it she'll just be like oh
whatever i'll just keep going
you guys are close huh that's
devastating
for you i would [ __ ] that's grounds for
termination
that's wild to me yeah she i tell her
not to tell me when she does it i would
rather not brush my teeth than know that
yeah that would bug me out yeah
i was worried my dad used my toothbrush
one time and it it grossed me out i
thought i loved my dad i love you buddy
but
he wouldn't want to use mine either all
right i got wood
i got one more this is from tom on
patreon uh have you ever prepared hot
food in a hotel room
[Laughter]
and he said the only the only acceptable
one is like a cup of noodles or
something sure
oh dear god yeah i did yeah a cup of
noodles is fine
especially when you're on the road
noodles no well so when when we first
moved to
atlanta we didn't have a place to stay
so we were living in a hotel
that was like a suite that like an
extension
stay type thing yeah those are tough
those are for people
in a jam i noticed while we were there
we were the only people that like we
would see people in the hallways we were
the only people
happy yeah everybody else is like had to
be there
damn holy [ __ ] sydney
kippy a garbage not garbage i'm not
fully sure but he's crazy i'll give him
that
i don't know i think it's a coin flip
garb i i i definitely wouldn't say
classy i definitely wouldn't say garbage
you're in the you know
the extended stay uh atlanta motel room
unfortunately put you over i would say
garbage yeah
60 garbage 40 class i i really
or normal i mean i i love the way this
episode went it was great but
i really feel like if there was the
stuff from the episode we lost
i think people would be like i don't
think he's garbage like he ca
it clearly you came from a tough
garbage setting your mother was fighting
in the streets
yeah that was on the first episode too
that's not going to be overlooked
yeah but not to mention the nursing home
file
that's [ __ ] dicey so here's here's a
funny thing about my mom
fighting in the streets a lot of times
she's getting these fights and these
women were trying to grapple her
so she'd come home with like no shirt no
bra
she'd walk home from the fight with her
titties out
confident like come into the house
remember she came in the house she
opened up the door
homework done like scratches all over
her chest and me and my brother were
like what the
[ __ ] and she goes she goes this is what
a champion looks like
she's like walked upstairs to a room
dude so
she's a [ __ ] boss yeah she's a she's
a she's a catchphrase person
she always she always says cool [ __ ] in
moments
yeah i love it i'll catch you what
ladies and gentlemen mr sydney again
sydney is that what the folks out there
know
uh uh no just uh check out two jack bros
uh myself and my my wife we're pretty
good
yeah social media uh at sydney gantt
on everything and then at two jack bros
on everything as well nice
gippy what do you got uh kevin ryan
comedy on all social media like i said
please make sure you review subscribe on
itunes
uh full video available on youtube
please subscribe there those numbers are
through the roof thank you for all the
support as well as patreon.com
guys the support we've gotten over this
podcast has been [ __ ] fantastic yes
honestly from the bottom of our hearts
we really appreciate it
thank you so much for the support gang
we love you toby we love you buddy and
people
at age foley on ice on twitter
foleygrams on instagram uh we will see
you
next week peace peace